good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight have you ever noticed
that there's not a single person in the
entire overstaffed Biden Administration
whose job it is to announce good news
not one there's the now familiar office
of attacking the middle class they're
usually quite busy there's the
department of new and counterproductive
Wars those people never sleep and of
course there's the all-powerful
directorate of Hysteria which makes sure
that every living American is terrified
of something or other from breakfast
till bed but there is no good news
office that's something that Biden
people never considered so yesterday the
administration seemed a little awkward
maybe even sheepish when it announced
the best news of all which is that the
covet era has finally passed
for three years the U.S has lived under
a permanent government designated covid
emergency at this point Looking Backward
no one can agree on what the point of it
was certainly nobody got any healthier
that's for sure in any case it's ending
for good or bad technically the
emergency will continue until May this
will allow the Bible Administration to
shovel a few more cargo planes full of
tax dollars to with donors in the
so-called Health Care industry
but that's it those The Last gasps of
The Rona scare we're done
and that means above all that we can
finally get to the second and much more
satisfying part of the program where we
finally hold the people accountable who
did what they just did to us and first
on that list would be Joe Biden at this
point Biden has the functional IQ of
office furniture but his instinctive
viciousness remains intact
so Biden the second he got into office
wasted no time at all in blaming
Americans for a virus that China created
and then in using the pandemic to pit
neighbors against one another
it was the cruelest and most divisive
thing any president has ever done to his
own country because you've forgotten
what it looked like here you go
I'm announcing that the Department of
Labor
is developing an emergency rule
to require all employers with 100 or
more employees that together employ over
80 million workers
to ensure their workforces
are fully vaccinated
or show a negative test at least once a
week we're going to protect vaccinated
workers from unvaccinated co-workers if
you've been patient
but our patients is wearing thin the
last thing we need is an Neanderthal
thinking that in the meantime
everything's fine take off your mask
forget it for unvaccinated we are
looking at a winner of severe illness
and death for unvaccinated for
themselves their families and the
hospitals they'll soon overwhelm
our patience is wearing thin Americans
if you want to take an untested
experimental mRNA shot from a company
that has bought immunity from Congress
against future lawsuits you're a selfish
Neanderthal worse you're a killer you're
literally literally killing your own
neighbors the only good news is you will
soon die yourself because you deserve it
that's what Joe Biden said president
said that to his own people and it was
of course a lie leaving aside its
potentially terrifying side effects the
shot did not work as advertised sorry it
just didn't it did not prevent people
from dying did not even prevent them
from transmitting or getting covered
themselves and that's why vaccinated
people still wear masks
everyone knows this but Joe Biden has
never admitted any of it nor has the
federal government rehired the thousands
of good people really the best people
the Navy Seals the nurses the EMTs the
firemen the airline pilots the people
who were fired from their jobs for
making what turned out to be a pretty
solid medical decision
by the way no one's ever explained why
it was immoral somehow to treat covid
before patients went up on respirators
why what was so bad about Ivermectin and
monoclonal antibody therapy we still
don't know
the administration still won't tell us
where the virus came from though
obviously they know the answer
but now is the time to find out we need
a Truth and Reconciliation Commission to
get the bottom of what we just lived
through and let's hope we get one very
soon
but in the meantime this being
Washington the end of kovid the end of
the emergency poses a much more
immediate political problem for the
people in charge the Democratic party
can't govern the country without
emergencies if the public is ever
allowed to calm down long enough to
think clearly uncomfortable questions
might emerge wait a second if my kid
can't get into a good college to work at
a big company because he's white how is
this systemic racism thing real
and if it is real why can't I just
change my race like all those people on
TV are always changing their sex just by
wishing it so what's the answer
can you imagine
asking questions like that that would be
bad it would be a disaster
so clearly Democratic party needs a new
emergency at least until we start
sending ground troops to Ukraine and the
population becomes suitably hysterical
again
so because they need an emergency they
found one and the new emergency turns
out to be the old emergency which is
white racism now unfortunately for the
Democratic party white racism is one
commodity
like cedar boards that's getting harder
to find very few unarmed black men are
killed by white cops these days where's
George Floyd when you need them so
instead in a pinch they've settled for
an unarmed black man killed by black
cops which they've informed us
nevertheless despite all appearances is
still the product of white racism and
Barack Obama enthusiastically agrees
this is Barack Obama's Lane
he was elected president twice on this
kind of stuff so he immediately jumped
into the middle of the Memphis tragedy
to remind us that white middle-class
Republicans did this blood is on their
hands Soma Dr King Rodney King Trayvon
Martin they're all the fruit of white
supremacy it's true and as Obama
explained on Twitter you can learn a lot
more about how it's true on his website
okay so we decided to go there we went
to the Obama Foundation website today
and there we found an entire section how
we have to continue to defund the police
yes people are still saying it quote
cities like Los Angeles Baltimore and
Philadelphia have reduced their budgets
for their police departments the Obama
Foundation explained without laughing
these Cuts made funding more available
for other elements of Public Safety like
affordable housing
right because affordable housing is
Public Safety unless that affordable
housing is in Chicago or Baltimore in
which case you're likely to be killed
but whatever
the point is take three steps back
Barack Obama the former president is
weighing in directly on America's latest
fake hate crime
and you have to wonder why he's not
doing it for himself Obama is retired at
this point he's living on Martha's
Vineyard with all the other rich white
people
he's doing it for his wife his wife
who's never had a real job and
apparently he's feeling kind of restless
approaching 60.
and that's why you may have noticed that
six years after leaving Washington
Michelle Obama is back in the news
she's got a new book and a media tour
and even a federally funded hiking trail
named for herself in Atlanta why has she
emerged in this way well there might be
a reason
in fact if you didn't know any better if
you were visiting this country from a
foreign land trying to figure out what's
going on in the U.S you might mistake
what Michelle Obama is doing right now
for the beginnings of a presidential
campaign
so first you have a manufactured white
racism Panic that's a clue
but the Clincher is menopause
unlike every other woman over 50 in all
human history Michelle Obama were sad to
tell you has menopause
it's not clear where she caught it maybe
there was an outbreak in Edgartown but
it's bad at one point Michelle Obama
gained up to six pounds you don't know
how much she suffered
let's put it this way but tan Death
March survivors she laughs at you
you can't fathom her pain watch her talk
about it on TV
I am still
quickly active and my goal now instead
of having Michelle Obama arms I just
want to keep moving just keep moving if
I can walk move I don't have to run I
don't have to beat everyone so I've had
to change the way I see myself in the in
it in my health space I never used to
weigh myself I'm not trying to stick to
numbers but when you're in menopause you
have this slow creep
you have this slow creep and no she's
not talking about Joe Biden here who is
technically one of the slowest Creeps in
America she's talking about her own
thighs now why does Michelle Obama
telling you about her menopausal thighs
on a TV show
possibly because she's a crazed
narcissist who thinks her own thighs are
interesting to you and that's of course
true but there may be other reasons
consider that today's Washington Post
expressed deep dissatisfaction with Joe
Biden's current Heir Kamal Harris
now Harris is a woman who cannot even
consistently pronounce her own first
name
and she might not be as the post
suggests up for the job of leading this
country and we're quoting some Democrats
are worried about Harris's political
prospects the paper says they're worried
she may not have the quote political
skills to win a national race
whoa wait a second pale colonizer Kamala
Harris doesn't have skills isn't that
racist
well as the post reports yes it is quote
some party members fear that Americans
are simply not willing to elect a woman
of color as president especially given
the racism and sexism they see emerging
in recent years because there's more now
so here's the problem for the Democratic
party the current vice president is
totally incompetent and universally
loathed by everyone including her staff
and possibly her husband who literally
kissed her with a mask on we're not
judging but you can see it for yourself
so you don't want her but you can't just
ditch her for a white dude sorry that's
not equity
so where do you go from here oh good
question and it turns out it's a
question that a Michelle Obama seems to
have been thinking about recently here
she is this fall considering the matter
of whether her elderly old servant sorry
her dear dear friend Joe Biden should
Grace this country with yet another term
as president watch
but it's a tough job and I think that
he's doing the the best he can under
some tough circumstances do you hope
that President Biden will run again in
2024 you know I I I
I will have to see it's you know the the
reason I don't speak on that is because
I know what it feels like to be on the
other side of it and I think that that's
a personal decision I don't want to be
one of the millions of people weighing
in on what he should do
he's doing uh pause here
the best he can that's where he runs
again Michelle Obama is going to have to
much longer pause here accompanied by
weird Sai she's going to have to quote
have to see about Joe Biden have to see
the question is will the rest of us have
to see a whole lot more of Michelle
Obama in the next two years
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight